hi I'm Eric Voss and I'm a big fan of
the Pixar movies actually really liked
cars 3 which I finally got around the
scene but like many of you I'm sure at
least those of you who weren't little
kids when these cars movies came out
just itching to buy toy and meters these
movies that have always seemed a little
weird to me like I know I'm not the
first person to ask
what the hell happened to the humans of
this world also how do the cars
reproduce like I can't be the only one
to think about it guys whoa ok the
Internet is a sick place and no not
because lightning and mater are both
guys like love is love is love just
maybe don't do this kind of thing to
Disney characters and sure there have
been many other over-analytical weirdos
like me out there who have spun out
their own crazy theories about the Pixar
extended universe specifically the world
of cars but now that cars 3 is out in
the world new rock stars is sharing the
darkest theories about the cars universe
that are fun to think about even if
they're kinda messed up and by staying
on this train of thought for far too
long we actually realized a few new
awful truths that we're gonna share with
you so buckle in kids let's get started
with the biggest question what are the
cars exactly specifically what is their
anatomical structure in biology and life
cycle for example Lightning McQueen wins
the opening race by a tongue so cars
have teeth and tongues apparently also
there were those two fangirls who
flashed their headlights at Lightning
basically implying that headlights are
boobs but then there's the most creepy
detail the cars have doors with handles
on those doors so like at some point
humans got inside and drove these things
so it's mater like we I got a family of
skeletons in my head git-r-done
oh good god we also know that there is a
car lifecycle so in cars 3 there's a
younger kid car who's a fan of lightning
so these things aren't just adults and
in cars too Bernoulli points to his
mother in the stands who looks exactly
like him so somehow these cars are
reproducing and making smaller baby cars
we also know that cars can get hurt and
die like for example we know that Doc
Hudson died somehow between cars and
cars too apparently there was a scene
cars three that was gonna address how
this happen but they cut it because yeah
it was super depressing
honestly the cars sequels took the
franchise to a lot of weird places cars
too is a random spy movie where we see
cars suit each other and blow each other
up and torture each other and crush each
other into cubes the movie also implies
that cars require oxygen
and that they eat and drink human food
like martinis and wasabi we also see
them take off their tires as if their
shoes and then we know that there are
different cars species and small plane
birds now there have been a few
terrifying theories to explain all of
this one idea from film theorists was
that the cars are actually exoskeletons
for other sentient beings that live
inside these automobiles shells so like
these beings could be super smart
insects or crustaceans or some kind of
alien like a lot of invertebrates have
exoskeletons and segmented bodies
similar to how cars are structured and a
lot of these creatures shed their husks
just like how the cars swap out their
parts that could also explain the car
lifecycle like these creatures just
crawl into new car bodies as they get
bigger and then when they get old they
crawl out and die so yeah kids that's
what happened to doc he's an old grumpy
bug who slithered out of a Hudson Hornet
whose corpse is now withering away
somewhere under the Arizona Sun now
before you call me crazy or cruel this
whole idea originated with Pixar itself
Jay Ward is Pixar's creative director of
the whole Cars universe and he wrote a
long document called the world of cars
owners manual and while that document is
probably locked away deep within the
Disney Vault we'll never get to see it
Ward was actually asked about the whole
door-handles thing and why cars doors
never opened and this is how he
responded he said you'll never see the
doors open because the brain and the
eyes are there we don't want anything
falling out the side that's right he
said brains these are space bugs people
of course if we interpret that quote as
a joke which we probably should there's
actually another statement from Ward
that points to an even darker theory
about where the cars come from he said
if you think about this we have
autonomous car technology coming in
right now and it's getting to the point
where you can sit back in the car and it
drives itself imagine in the near future
when cars keep getting smarter and
smarter and after one day they just go
why do we need human beings anymore
they're just slowing us down it's just
extra weight let's get rid of them but
the car takes on the personality of the
last person who drove it holy crap
now this explanation is in
or approved by Pixar in any way but even
if part of it is true this is super dark
he's saying that these cars are evolved
artificial intelligence that murdered
billions of humans like terminators and
then transform themselves into car
versions of those humans I guess also
like terminators and people are saying
that if this is the case doc could have
been an actual Hudson Hornet driven by
the actual late Paul Newman who did the
voice of the character Newman was also
known to be a car collector in a racing
enthusiast now yes I know this idea is
still pretty creepy but it actually
brings up an even deeper mystery about
the whole cars universe what universe do
the cars live in so Jay Ward's theory
actually kind of legitimizes part of
that popular Pixar universe theory
that's been around for a while so the
gist of that is that all the Pixar
movies are connected in one shared
universe kind of like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and that the cars in
the cars movies are advanced versions of
the AI robots left behind on earth and
wall-e and that they're now inhabiting
the earth as their own cars version of
humanity now that theory definitely has
a few holes and actually Phillip and Sam
came up with a whole new interesting
theory that explains things a lot better
their idea was basically that the world
of cars is a separate universe within
the Pixar universe and that the
adventures of lightning and mater or
Aldous fictional stories that the human
characters of Toy Story and Finding Nemo
and ratatouille and inside-out all
watching their TV shows and movies and
imagine as they're playing with their
toys lightning and mater now their
theory isn't totally bulletproof but you
should definitely go watch that video
for more information on that because
it's super interesting but I want to go
deeper into this Cars universe
specifically their history now a lot of
visual clues show up in the movies that
imply a parallel timeline to our human
timeline and yeah let's be honest our
history is pretty damn violent so let's
pose a question what horrible things
have the cars done to each other and
let's start with recent history now as I
mentioned before the cars and cars to
take off their tires like their shoes
specifically they do this while going
through airport security now of course
in the real world the reason airport
security makes us take our
Jews off is that attempted shoe bomber
back in 2001 a few months after the 9/11
attacks now I am NOT saying that the
cars universe had its own 9/11 but the
cars apparently do take the threat of
terrorism very seriously so either some
horrible car bombing did take place or
as some have pointed out the planes and
cars are also sentient so maybe some
planes got radicalized and became
suicide bombers ah you get the idea so
I'm going to move on from this dark line
of thinking to something even darker
okay let's look at the character Sarge
in Radiator Springs Sarge is a World War
2 era Jeep his character bio mentions
that he fought at the Battle of the
Bulge in World War two he also at one
point called lightning a commie
meanwhile the hippy VW Bus Fillmore
called lightning a fascist
so this evidence along with the world
war two ERA Navy plane in the movie
planes who mention that he fought in a
battle in the Pacific are all proof that
yeah there were world wars in the Cars
universe and I apologize but I have to
bring this up what caused the second
world war in human history specifically
which famous fascist dictator that's
right guys there was a car's Hitler now
we could speculate over what kind of car
cars Hitler would be my first thought
was some kind of German car like a
Volkswagen or BMW but when you think
about it Hitler was technically Austrian
not German so maybe that would make him
like a Magna Steyr but then also there
was a cars Arnold Schwarzenegger who's
also Austrian and he was a Hummer I
don't know guys given all the horrible
things that we saw the cars do to each
other in cars too I really don't like to
think about how far cars Hitler could
have gone or how he might have used
those sentient trains of that universe
they must feel awful ok let's move on to
another weird implication the cars
universe a car's religion now in cars
too we see a cars Pope wearing a little
Pope hat riding inside of a cars
popemobile now I got to say that just
the idea of sentient vehicles riding
inside of other Scindia vehicles is
already pretty off-putting but let's
face it the cars universe
took a big step by bringing organized
religion into this because for one now
things are getting existential like is
there a cars hell Roman Catholic
doctrine is pretty clear about their
beliefs in heaven and hell so like is
car I'm a sexuality seen as a sin if so
do not show cars Pope that picture
lightning tomater don't show anyone that
stop showing it in this video please but
besides those big questions the
existence of a car Roman Catholic Church
means that that whole dark history
exists too like a car's Spanish
Inquisition cars sex abuse scandals cars
Crusades and yes a cars Jesus who died
on a cross now I mean to be too negative
you know maybe depending on your
believes this could be a good thing for
the cars look I just don't want to have
this conversation right now thanks for
making it operat cars too but one final
unsettling theory of this cars universe
is something I just realized while
watching these movies again and if you
watch closely there is absolutely a
car's class structure so yes I'm sorry
but apparently not all cars are equal
most cars like lightning and Sally they
have four wheels and no real appendages
like sometimes they'll gesture with
their front wheels or they'll use their
side mirrors to hold objects like
cameras but there's another class of
cars that perform functions that require
more dexterous use of appendages these
are called the pities these are the
smaller forklifts that work in the pit
crews like weed Oh seriously that's his
name that's that's not cool right but
really pities do all sorts of jobs
they're bartenders and janitors sushi
chefs musicians oil rig workers those
guys on airport tarmacs with the little
flashlights and State Farm Insurance
reps who clean up city blocks can't
always be prepared
[Music]
[Applause]
let's face it guys pitties are the
blue-collar and service industry workers
of the cars world and while all the
political and business leaders are
four-wheel cars like Range Rovers and
Aston Martin's and Rolls Royces no pity
has ever risen to any position of power
that sucks I pity the pity in fact even
though most of the cars characters are
available as toys with their own names
and backstories one of these pities is
just named not Chuck he is the forklift
and lightnings original pit crew in the
first movie whose name lightning doesn't
even bother to learn Disney won't even
give this video name now sure in the
cars movies no car is more blue collar
than mater who's the breakout star of
the franchise in the hero of the second
film he's also extremely stupid and he
thinks that wasabi is pistachio ice
cream so I don't know maybe not the best
representation of the working class also
let's not forget he's a car how the hell
does he know what pistachio ice cream is
now I don't mean to hate on these movies
Pixar actually poked fun at themselves
in cars 3 there's a great joke with
lightly and asking if its new race car
body comes with a phone and he's just
told that race cars don't have phones
and I get it these movies aren't for
nitpicky adults like me they're for kids
who love toys and I can get behind that
Radiator Springs racers the distant land
is so freakin fun just don't think too
hard about these things aah Oh God what
is the weirdest theory that you've heard
about the cars universe and what moment
if any took you out of these movies the
most also do you think cars three
restored the franchise back to these
simple charms of the first movie let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and share this video around to
help expose these dark terrifying truths
and of course like this video and
subscribe to new rockstars and if I made
these beloved Disney movies feel gross
for you now you're welcome but if you're
not too mad feel free to share your
thoughts with me directly on twitter at
EA vas you can also follow new rockstars
on twitter at new rockstars for updates
on their videos thanks for watching and
channel never
get guys